wird Politik für alte Leute gemacht ja
natürlich also wie Herr Schulz wie Herr
Schulz wie Herr Schulz das vorhin
beschrieben hat man muss aufpassen dass
das demografische Problem nicht
irgendwann zum demokratischen Problem
wird also man hätte ja auch sagen können
statt dass wir jedes Jahr 12 Milliarden
Euro für die Rente mit 63 ausgeben geben
wir die gleiche Summe für Investition in
Digitalisierung aus ähm um unser Land
fit für die Zukunft zu machen und ich
persönlich glaube
dass die Politik in den letzten Jahren
und zwar unabhängig von der
Parteipolitik da nehme ich meine Partei
wie jede andere genau mit
leideror ma ich auch mache ich auch und
da hat jede
Bundesregierung ja diese
Zukunftsinvestition sie sagen man legt
sich mit mit den
silvurfern mit denen legt man sich nicht
an ich zeig jetzt nicht auf sie aber mit
den mit den Silver sind rtisch unterweg
genau ich bin schon ist schon durch das
themaau genau